If you want to hear my theory about what Chucky’s
original plan may have been and how it was
altered in desperation, then stick around
to the end of this video.
Welcome back to Things You Missed, the show
where I find the most thoughtful and intelligent
analysis and discussion about horror cinema,
except we’re covering a movie about a dumb
kid and a killer doll who at one point blows
up a house, so let’s just throw all that
intelligent analysis stuff out the window
with Aunt Maggie and get into the Things You
Missed.
The movie begins in Chicago, where serial
killer Charles Lee Ray is fleeing from the
police.
I heard online somewhere that the name Charles
Lee Ray comes from combining the names of
serial killer Charles Manson, and assassins
Lee Harvey Oswald and James Earl Ray, and
I only wish that he would have actually succeeding
in taking over Andy Barclay’s body, because
that would have may him Charles Barkley.
Apparently before Jimmy Wong was on Feasts
of Fiction, he also ran his own Cantonese
restaurant, outside of which Charles Lee Ray
gets shot.
Anyone find it a little strange that he bleeds
more in his doll form than he does as a human?
Anyways, he flees into the Toy Shop, and one
thing I found kind of interesting here is
that the front window of this place, Playland
Toys shows all of these toys driving cars,
and that’s like the one thing Chucky can’t
do.
In all of the sequels he has to either hitch
a ride or threaten someone to drive him somewhere.
There’s also a picture of Humpty Dumpty
right here next to this French duck, and that
could a foreshadowing about Maggie falling
down the 8th story window later.
That could just be a coincidence, but I will
note that this wasn’t just a Toy Store that
they filmed in, this was built for the movie,
and also destroyed for the movie.
When Ray is breaking into the store, there’s
a game near the window called Fireball Island,
which from what I can tell is a game about
a cursed volcano, and Charles shoots in that
direction to open the door.
This could be a parallel to Chucky being a
cursed doll, who is eventually killed when
they shoot it in the heart.
Again, those are questionably intentional,
but here’s one that definitely isn’t intentional,
but I found kind of interesting anyway.
When the title comes on screen, all the letters
are capitalized besides A and I, and in the
2019 version of Child’s Play, Chucky is
an AI, an artificial intelligence.
As the dying Charles makes his way through
the store, he keeps saying he’s gotta find
somebody.
“I’ve gotta find somebody.
I’ve gotta find somebody.”
Then when he knocks over the stack of Good
Guy dolls, he look surprised, as if an idea
has just hit him.
I think he memorized the voodoo incantation
with the intention of transferring his soul
into another human in case he ever got in
trouble, but since there were no humans around,
he figured his best bet was to try to send
it into the doll, and by a stroke of luck,
it worked.
He even tells John Bishop later that we was
kind of surprised that it worked.
The next day, is our protagonist Andy Barclay’s
birthday.
He gets up early to watch his favorite show,
Good Guys.
Roll it.
“No one will play with me.”
“Uh oh.
There’s a friend in need.
Hey cheer up!”
“Who are you?”
“I am Doctor Rabbit!”
No, but what I actually wanted to point out
was this kid in the cartoon has a target on
his chest, just as Andy becomes the target
of Chucky after learning that he is the only
one that he’ll be able to transfer his soul
into.
Andy isn’t interested in the show though,
because he’s apparently already seen it,
so he returns to the kitchen so he can continue
being a complete brat.
The brand of the bread he uses for his mother’s
toast is “good stuff” which matches the
constant Good Guys branding on almost everything
he owns.
I’m genuinely surprised that they didn’t
make this Good Guys mascot the villain of
the entire movie instead of the doll, he’s
way creepier.
Look at this thing.
Imagine this chasing after you in a dark alley.
Would have been way better.
At the end of that commercial we hear the
following:
“Brought to you exclusively by Play Pals,
makers of Good Guys and other fine toys.
Found in Toy Stores throughout the greater
Chicago area.”
Play Pals would later play a more prominent
role in the sequel Child’s Play 2, though
there looks to be an error later in the movie
where it says Play Partners Toys on the Good
Guy box instead of Play Pals.
Close enough I guess.
Speaking of errors, when Andy, sees that commercial,
that the first time he’s hearing about The
Good Guy doll.
“Wow!!”
Then he goes into the other room wakes up
his Mom, then she lets him open his birthday
presents.
“Well what do you think?”
“I want a Good Guy to go with it.”
“I know you do Andy--”
Wait, hold up, stop it right there.
No.
No you didn’t know he wanted a Good Guy.
He just found out about it five minutes ago
while you were asleep.
Alright, let’s continue.
Andy’s Mom is able to buy the doll from
a peddler and give it Andy.
The design of the Good Guy doll is based off
of the My Buddy Doll from the 80s.
“My Buddy.
My Buddy.
MY BUDDY!”
Andy’s Mom has to work late, so her friend
Maggie watches Andy that night.
As she’s turning off the TV, a news report
talks about, Eddie Caputo who escaped during
a prison bus transfer on his way to court.
You’ll already know about this if you’ve
seen the movie multiple times, but it’s
not as obvious on a first watch.
Eddie was Charles’s accomplice the night
before at the toy store who bailed out picking
him up in the van.
“Eddie!
Eddie don’t leave me, God no!”
So Chucky goes after him later and blows up
his hideout.
"WTF BOOM--"
Also, the news station is called W-DOL.
You know, cause Chucky’s a doll.
Chucky pushes Maggie out of the window where
she falls harder than James Charles’s career,
so Karen ends up coming home to an apartment
full of cops.
"What?"
“Ms Peterson’s dead Ms Barclay.”
“What?’
Wait, how are you surprised by that?
After this?
"Nothing to see, now let's move it..."
And after this?
“Mrs. Barclay, I’m detective Mike Norris,
homicide.”
So the cops clear out after he explains everything,
and the next day Karen takes her son to school…
and let’s him bring the Chucky doll with?
This is almost as bad as when that kid brought
his cat to school in Pet Sematary 2.
Yeah, this video really took a wrong turn
if we’re talking about Pet Sematary 2 again.
Andy skips school and Chucky makes him go
to Eddie’s hideout so he can get his revenge.
The police find Andy and pick him up, where
they discover he believes Chucky is alive
and send him in for a mental evaluation.
Karen is left to give Chucky a closer look.
At the apartment, there’s a photo of a guy
in a red shirt.
I’m guessing that’s supposed to be Andy’s
deceased father, they have the same photo
all over the house, but it’s actually just
the director of the movie, Tom Holland.
He also makes a cameo as the voice during
that creepy commercial I mentioned earlier.--
Chucky tries to kill officer Norris, and is
almost successful, but Norris ends up shooting
him, and Chucky discovers he’s able to feel
pain, so he hits up his pal John Bishop, the
voodoo doctor, to try to figure out how to
remedy the situation.
He learns that his doll form is becoming human
and Chucky threatens him with a voodoo doll
to try to get more information.
“You shouldn’t tell your customers where
you hide things like this John.”
Wait, so we are to believe that John made
a voodoo doll of himself?
Why?
How would that?
You know what, **** it, let’s just continue
on with this video.
"AGHHHH!!!"
“So long Jonn”.
And so, Chucky learns he must transfer his
soul into the person who he first revealed
himself to, which of course is Andy.
So Chucky tries to break into the hospital
where the little **** is being kept and all
the sudden he’s freaking massive on the
stairs.
Look at this, it’s like that mascot I was
talking about earlier.
And are we really supposed to believe that
Andy, the kid who could not even pour a bowl
of cereal properly, was clever enough to set
that bait with the pillow and escape when
Chucky came in?
And one more thing, why do they have this
shock device, which apparently is capable
of killing a grown man, in a children’s
hospital?
And another thing, how does a 6 year old kid
find his way home on the streets of Chicago
by himself?
And it’s winter, and I’m assuming he’s
never been to this hospital before.
Alright.
I’ll stop ragging on this movie now.
….
No I won’t.
Obvious reference to Halloween.
Obvious reference to The Shining.
Andy’s Mom gets home and manages to trap
Chucky in the fireplace, and we actually get
a pretty cool one liner from Andy.
“Andy, no please.
We’re friends to the end, remember?”
“This is the end, friend.”
It isn’t.
They blow Chucky’s head off, he comes back.
They blow his arm off.
He comes back.
And then finally, they figure it out!
For some reason, you have to shoot it in the
heart!
“The heart!
Shoot him in the heart!”
Cue the Bov Jovi end credits song!
What?
No Shot Through The Heart?
Are you kidding me?
This was the 80s!
The song came out like two years before this
movie!
It would have been perfect.
Alright, whatever.
Click the video on the left if you want to
see some Things You Missed in the teaser trailer
and ARG for the new Child’s Play remake.
Next week I’m doing Child’s Play 2 and
3, and of course I’ll be doing the new movie
when it comes out.
So, here’s what you gotta do.
Subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.